what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios is
going to be going through some changes
now before anybody starts to freak out
pretty badly I do believe that these are
going to be really good changes that are
much needed with Marvel Studios right
now and if we can suffer through some
date changes and delays I think
ultimately the MCU will be better
unfortunately that does mean we do have
to suffer a little bit but let's talk
about how this is really a good thing
also big congrats to YouTube user Army
Onslaught for winning the next giveaway
don't worry we are still doing more
giveaways so if you want a chance to win
a Marvel Legends item be sure to
subscribe and comment down below now we
knew that some changes were coming when
Disney fired Bob chapek and brought Bob
Iger back on board and based off of
everything that we've heard which is
rumors at this point in time nothing
from Disney officially but based off of
those Rumblings that we would hear Bob
chapek really had a priority of pushing
Disney plus subscriber numbers he was
more about the numbers whereas Bob Iger
before it was more about creativity of
course he was about numbers to an extent
of course he was the CEO but he
understood that good quality content
would bring in subscribers and viewers
and fans to the movie theaters so Marvel
Studios put out so much content within
the past two years that they almost put
out just as much content that they did
in the first 11 years of the entirety of
the MCU which is insane to think about
they did just about 11 years worth of
work in two years so when people started
to complain about phase four kind of
being more about quantity over quality
they were kind of correct but it wasn't
exactly Marvel studios's fault also I
don't think phase 4 was that bad in fact
in my next video coming out this
afternoon I have guests on Chris from
cosmic culture and Wendy from the movie
couple we're going to talk about that so
be sure to look out for that in a few
hours but phase four was a building
phase however you could certainly start
to note notice that the quality started
to lack and apparently ever since Bob
eicher got back the focus is kind of
Shifting again back to that creative
side and quality side moreover quantity
so unfortunately that means some things
are probably going to get pushed back
and today we have a report from somebody
over at the cosmic circus Alex P that
suggests that some changes are indeed
going to be coming to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe timeline and
unfortunately that means a pushback in
the Spider-Man 4 release date now with
the Spider-Man 4 release date probably
being pushed back there's actually good
news and bad news to this the bad news
is that with it being pushed back it's
probably going to be released in 2025
instead of any time in 2024. originally
the cosmic circus reported that
Spider-Man 4 should have a release date
of July of 2024. however not only is
Marvel Studios probably going to have
some changes but Sony as well seemingly
is making changes too Sony was marked
down for attending CC cxp they even
announced it on the ccxp website and
Sony announced it themselves however
eventually Sony ended up backing out and
the reports for this state that the
reason they were backing out is because
some of their big picture films moved
release dates so they didn't want to
talk about them yet and we assumed that
Spider-Man 4 was one of these release
dates Spider-Man 4 is confirmed make no
mistake about that Kevin feige the
president of Marvel Studios and
executive producer over at Sony Amy
Pascal have already confirmed this they
confirmed this about a week after
Spider-Man no way home hit theaters and
not to mention Tom Rothman the CEO of
Sony a couple of days ago came out and
said yes Spider-Man 4 is indeed
happening so make no mistake Spider-Man
4 is coming either in Phase 5 or phase
six but Tom Rothman also said when it's
coming I don't know so Sony most likely
has pushed back the release date for
Spider-Man 4 due to something internally
it could be contracts it could be trying
to get old actors back or new actors to
play a new villain who knows but at this
point in time we've heard a lot of
reports about a new Spider-Man contract
with the MCU and Sony but I want to
clarify this isn't a contract between
Tom Holland and Sony not yet this is
simply for Spider-Man to remain in the
MCU Spider-Man the character so there is
a difference between Tom Holland's
contract and the contract for the
character Spider-Man because if they
wanted to they absolutely should not but
if they wanted to they could recast
Spider-Man they could recast Tom Holland
and still have a Spider-Man in the MCU
but again that would be an absolutely
terrible idea and there's no way they
should do that unless it's like Miles
Morales but it can't be Peter Parker
they can't recast Tom Holland already
but the report is apparently for three
solo Spider-Man films so another Trilogy
and then three other group projects two
of them are Avengers King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars so that's five
different projects and the sixth one is
kind of a mystery right now it could be
another group film or could be
Spider-Man appearing in the Daredevil
series fingers crossed for that but
unfortunately we don't really know right
now but here's the good news even if we
do get some delays Spider-Man 4 does
have to come out before Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars because we know Spider-Man
is going to show up in both of those and
the story of Spider-Man does kind of
have to be finished at least the story
of no way home and Spider-Man 4. before
we get to these big group films where
the other Avengers interact with
Spider-Man because the story of nobody
knowing his identity now we have to go
through that before we get to these team
up films so even if Spider-Man 4 does
get delayed the good news is it still
has to come relatively soon now Alex P
from the cosmic circus thinks that it's
probably coming in 2025 now rather than
getting pushed back to sometime in 2024
like winter of 2024 it's most likely
coming in 2025 sometime hopefully we
don't have to wait as long as a year but
as long as we get this movie in Phase 5
I think we're going to be okay now
having said that I do think there's
going to be [ __ ] shifts in Phase 5 and
Phase 6 as schedules as it is and what
will most likely happen is they'll
probably push everything back just a
little bit take each project and push it
back maybe two months each and of course
I know a lot of fans don't really want
this but this is what I was talking
about in the beginning where I stated
that this is probably a good thing if
we're trying to focus on quality not
quantity but quality this is a good
thing because this means we'll still get
the same amount of projects however
Marvel Studios will give the projects
more time to be focused on improving the
quality that and it's going to be a lot
easier for the workers over at Disney
we've already heard stories about
workers working way over time and that
is because they had such a tight
schedule before trying to get all of
these movies and Disney Plus shows and
special presentations out I don't want
to see the schedule pushed back any more
than anybody else does But ultimately I
do think that it's going to be a good
thing if they do decide to do this and
it does sound like they are gonna do it
however I will say that the Sony
decision to push back Spiderman and 4
could be a decision on their own and
that could be made completely separate
from Marvel Studios because after all
Sony does kind of have the final Say
with Spider-Man especially when it comes
to when the movie comes out and the
marketing and everything for that and
announcing the movie that's all up to
Sony it's always done by Sony Marvel
Studios never does it in fact it's never
even included and the slates for Marvel
Studios so there is always the chance
that Marvel Studios might not really
push things back too much and that
Sony's decision was separate however
like I said I do think it should be
pushed back a little bit the entire
Phase 5 and phase six slate just to give
Marvel Studios and the workers more time
to focus on that quality so phase five
can be better than phase four and also
phase six better than phase five and
also hopefully going forward every phase
kind of be better in quality at least
than the previous phase strictly
speaking about quality because obviously
One Division was never going to be as
good as Avengers end game that's not a
very good comparison and whatever comes
after Secret Wars isn't going to be as
good as sacred Wars however the quality
of the content can be up there but let
us know your thoughts about these
possible changes in the comments down
below what do you think is it a good
thing or a bad thing don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to stay up
to date on all the latest news for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof